es considerada como una arma atómica
dentro del mundo financiero tras largas
discusiones países europeos y sus
aliados occidentales han decidido cortar
el acceso de bancos rusos a la
plataforma interbancaria swift un
sistema de mensajería esencial dentro de
las transacciones financieras
internacionales no nos dan gas
primero nos comprometemos al aislamiento
de varios bancos rusos del sistema swift
esto conducirá a la desconexión del
sistema financiero internacional y su
capacidad de actuar globalmente se verá
debilitada las capas y lleida y el globo
no soft juzga a felix en concreto esta
exclusión impedirá que los bancos rusos
realicen la mayor parte de sus
transacciones internacionales y también
puede bloquear las importaciones y
exportaciones rusas una medida con
efectos devastadores que dividían los
europeos pero en los últimos días países
como austria y hungría dieron un giro y
solamente alemania dependiente del gas
ruso mostraba oposición la unión europea
también está atacando los activos del
banco central ruso
nos
paralizaremos los activos del banco
central de rusia esto congelará sus
transacciones financieras y hará
imposible liquidar sus activos
imposible la liquidación de seis active
el objetivo golpear la billetera rusa
para limitar su capacidad de financiar
la guerra en ucrania adicionalmente a
los oligarcas rusos se les negará el
acceso a los mercados europeos medidas
que serán sometidas a la votación de los
estados miembros en los próximos días